et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
avec adel bat khawani directeur du
département de recherche de l'institut
de recherches et d'études méditerranée
moyen-orient bonjour et merci d'être en
direct avec nous donc augmentation des
effectifs militaires en irak 200 cents à
4000 cette décision est forte pourquoi
parce que tout simplement la main assez
forte
alors autres deux dash n'est plus une
hypothèse mais un phénomème une réalité
concrète
l'organisation de l'état islamique
conduit des opérations non seulement
dans nos territoires
les territoires disputés mais aussi à
bagdad la capitale
oui la menace est forte les attentats
sont effectivement de nombreux sur le
sol irakien est ce que ce renforcement
des troupes de l'otan peut changer
quelque chose
oui absolument absolument pas ce que l
état d des forces de sécurité irakiennes
dollar mais la tienne mais oublie si dts
malgache au niveau de formation au
niveau d'accompagnement au niveau
d'équipement au niveau du financement
mais aussi au niveau de l'organisation
est très très fragile
ces forces de sécurité irakiennes à la
fois dans l'eau nord et dans dans les
rapts arabes ne sont absolument pas
aujourd'hui en mesure
objectivement parlant de répondre à
cette menace de l'organisation d' états
islamiques
alors d'après un diplomate
il se pourrait que ces 4000 hommes
déployés sur le territoire irakien
enfin que ça ne se fasse pas de manière
en tout cas immédiate ça devrait être
graduelle est ce que ça peut avoir pour
conséquence d'enliser la situation sur
le terrain la situation sécuritaire
écoutez je pense personnellement c'est
une énorme et nous pas là c'est une
porte d'ouverture une porte de sortie de
la crise actuellement à la crise qui
ravage les rails d'irak
crise sécuritaire crise d'organisation
prise de réponse l'état islandais l'état
irakien pardo il ya aujourd'hui il est
vraiment démunis face à l'organisation
mais aussi il faut le dire immédiatement
face à face à des organisations
milicienne à l'état irakien epr est
prise en étau prison en neige en otage à
la fois par l'organisation de l'état
islamique qui se présente comme l
expression de la communauté sunnite
l'expression politique de la communauté
sunnite mais aussi par les organisations
milicienne et qui se prennent pour la
représentation de la communauté chez
alors donc que la mission de l'alliance
atlantique est bien évidemment fortement
recommandée mais sera très très complexe
en même temps est-ce que vous pensez que
donc ce déploiement de 4000 hommes sera
suffisant pour faire face à la situation
sur le terrain non non absolument pas
absolument pas là alors un réengagement
des états unis d'amérique mais aussi des
forces occidentales sont fortement
recommandé d'avoir nécessaire nécessaire
ici et maintenant immédiatement et nous
pas demain et nous pas dans un an
pourquoi parce que tout simplement comme
je vous ai dit l armée irakienne et des
appareils de sécurité nous sont
absolument pas en mesure aujourd'hui
réagir face à cette menace qui hélas ici
et maintenant à là tout de suite
autrement dit ce n'est pas une menace
qui est en cours qui ont perspective
c'est une menace qui est là et et qui
peuvent faire des dégâts à toutes les
échelles au niveau de l'état irakien
mais aussi de l'autre côté des
frontières pas seulement lire à qui les
états du système régional déploiement
renforcer en irak et dans l'autre côté
le retrait de
des troupes en afghanistan n'est pas à
l'ordre du jour pourquoi cette décision
est-elle si difficile à prendre
ben parce que tout simplement le moyen
orient d'une manière générale passe par
par une phase très sensible
une telle décision aura des conséquences
sur le moyen terme et le long terme il
faut évaluer tout tout tout être toutes
les taux de toutes les échelles tous les
niveaux avant prendre une telle décision
merci beaucoup à del bacco wayne d'avoir
répondu à ces questions je rappelle que
vous êtes directeur du département de
recherche de l'institut de recherches et
d'études méditerranée au moyen-orient
merci à vous